well lately many viewers have been
telling us they're having to wait
months for an appointment at the dmv
which is making it really tough to
handle
urgent deadlines for their cars now one
viewer said that although he has an
appointment in march
his car was towed from his apartment
because of it had an expired
registration
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to the dmv and also shares
how to prevent this from happening to
you i'm feeling
uh really overwhelmed a little bit
anxious
mike moss moved to nevada in october
while waiting for his march dmv
appointment to register his car
he got this yellow notice from his
apartment complex
stating his car would be towed for a
registration violation
just on the way out there was five cars
right there in the front building
with all these with these type of
stickers ma says although he has shown
proof of an appointment
the apartment complex is not being
lenient
where i'm living like i don't feel like
they understand that
i'm not doing this on purpose i'm not
there and i'm not breaking your laws on
purpose
like many other drivers waiting for a
dmv appointment
moss feels stuck on what to do next i
reached out to the nevada dmv
for answers we have a lot of online
services
that people may not be aware of so our
advice is always to go on the website
first
kevin malone with the dmv says
registration is in high demand
a renewal can be done online at a dmv
kiosk or by mail
if you're like moss and just moved here
or if you bought your car from a private
party
you'll need to register in person the
dmv understands that appointments fill
up quickly
so they highly suggest getting a
movement permit in the meantime
this permit lasts 60 days with a maximum
of 180 days the intent is to
give you some time to make an
appointment drivers can apply for a
movement permit online
or at a dmv location no appointment
necessary
kate houston 8 news now another service
that's in high demand is license
renewals which can also be done
on the dmv website the department has
helped renew though more than 50
000 licenses since the online program
was launched this year
a